[Music]
welcome to the eviction 2022.
over the next few weeks you're going to
have a series of very intense property
investment challenges and the winner is
going to be given 20 000 pounds cash
prize to help kick-start your property
investment Journey
with the help of various mentors that
are going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges I'll decide who stays
and who gets evicted
because you needed to be spoon-fed wow
just don't lie to me don't call me alone
I'm not going to lie down and take it
can I have a break
about the Coronation Street isn't it
you're evicted
[Music]
congratulations for getting through to
round two you've demonstrated that you
are good at staging properties and you
know how to Market a property and that's
a really important part of being an
entrepreneur however one of the most
important skills to be a property
entrepreneur is to be able to sell
so you have 24 hours
and in those 24 hours each team you've
got a source of property investment
you've got to find it package it and
you've got to sell the deal that you
found to an investor for a finders fee
now I've done this I got dropped in
London in my Underpants and I wasn't
allowed to use any of my contacts and I
made three thousand pounds within 24
hours you you've got 24 hours you're in
teams you're allowed to use your current
contacts and database and estate agent
friends and I would expect that you
should be able to make at least three
thousand pounds profit within 24 hours
per team
now the winning team will be the team
that makes the most money at selling
deals the losing team there will be two
more evictions in the next boardroom
so that's the challenge I want to now
tell you who your teams are in and who
your team leaders are team one is going
to be fiery Jody
d
Nick
and Adam
team two is going to be Matt
Adriana
Scott
and shirelle
now on the last challenge shirelle you
kind of operated a little bit of a team
leader anyway and I want to see how well
you're going to perform under pressure
as the official team leader so you're
going to be team leader of your team and
this team Nick you're going to be team
leader be interesting to see how you get
on with jodo
you can have mentors to go with you to
help you with sales contracts and any
support that you might need throughout
this challenge you've only got 24 hours
you've got a lot to get done so next
team you're going to have a mentor with
you who is a very very dear friend of
mine he's personally sold hundreds of
deals before so he knows how to sell
deals and your Mentor is going to be
Elliot Spencer
[Music]
shirelle's team you're also going to
have a mentor with you who's also a very
close friend of mine that's a sales
expert and knows the market the property
Market inside out your Mentor is going
to be Chris jevons
the money that you make you're going to
be able to keep as well so if you make
10 grand two grand whatever you make you
can split amongst you and keep but I'm
going to be having to evict two people
in 24 hours so
go make some money off you go
[Music]
[Music]
I am a team player I'm able to
understand what the vision is as a group
and play my role and I will play that
role to the maximum as if it was just
for me because ultimately if the team
wins I win okay guys winning team let's
get this started
so we have to view it we have to make
money we have to sell it so I'm thinking
we can keep it simple within an hour of
where we are kind of like reading
Windsor Slough areas so if we
concentrate in one area at a time for a
couple hours maybe before moving on it
makes our packs going together a lot
easier as well so we can kind of split
things out yeah so you're going to focus
on different property types or just one
I mean the ideal I think would be rent
to rent but what do you think is going
to sell the quickest
we target maybe rent events because with
your bras sometimes you've got to put
too much work together and convince the
investor so do you think we get over
that threshold and then pump it up and
try and get like the BR deals that are
going to sell for more 100 because we're
looking in Reading what I'm going to do
is I'm going to get the data so what
kind of average nightly rate are we
looking for and then that means what
kind of rents are we kind of going for
okay
the first thing you need with deal
sourcing is to find amazing deals that
have a good Roi so the guys at the
moment they're trying to scour right
move zoopla Gumtree to find these really
good deals it doesn't necessarily matter
what their strategy is it can be rent to
rent brrs lease options it's just do the
numbers Stacks they're going through the
numbers seeing how much properties are
renting out for in the area collating
all the information doing all the due
diligence then they're going to jump on
the phones in a minute and try and book
some viewings in
I've had a number of careers throughout
my life but every time I have changed
careers I've always gone on to kind of
be the best of the best during the
pandemic I lost my job and I thought
fantastic it's a great opportunity to go
two feet in to property so right now I
run a property management business
specializing in rent to rent I also sell
luxury real estate as well
right guys what's the plan that's what
we're doing so we've got to find the
deal 24 hours the time is of the essence
so just a quick one Samuel has said that
any investors you've already worked with
or that you know you can tap into them
and you can get in touch with them so
how many investors have we got at the
minute between us that we know of I know
that I got free for rent to essays yeah
I have three then to rent but internet
is very popular
sell it in an hour just remember guys
rent to rent it's a numbers game the
more phone calls on that you make the
more leads you'll generate the more
viewings you'll get but you've got to
put the timing on the phones so there's
four of you pick an area each just just
smash smash the phones get the viewings
hi there how are you I'm just ringing up
our property appetizers is that still
available key thing I'm looking for is
the landlord is open to a company let
it's for investment purposes and how
many bedrooms is that I'm in quite a
rush it's afternoon or tomorrow
challenge is it's essentially hard
however this is how I think everybody
should treat deal sourcing because
they've got urgency because they've got
a 24-hour window that's what's making
them work extra hard I think in my
experience that urgency is what gets
results
booked a bureau in Reading he's just
confirmed that yeah it's a lot of
viewing booked in for 4 45. good man
I think what they need to do to win in
the next 24 hours is focus on getting
that report with an investor now they've
said they've got investors but I'm not
sure they actually know what the
investors are looking for so if I was
there might be on the phones now just
asking them hey I've found some
properties if I find X Y and Z in the
next 12 hours 24 hours are you in a
position to move forward
foreign
[Music]
record
all right how's your team getting on all
right all right we've got some
potentials well yeah potentials bring
money in don't they potential is great
yeah all right my team's doing really
well I don't want to give too much away
we've got more than potential what's
your team strategy we're playing to our
strengths I will tell you they've got
they've got viewings booked in for
tonight okay around here so about 40
minutes away they've actually gone now
and they're looking at all different
types of properties we're not just
focusing on one rent to rent brrs and
they've gone through their contact list
and kind of identify the investors that
they think will match up to the
properties they have they have been
really good to be fair because you're
stronger to be honest they're all
they're all quite strong shirelle is
she's leading the group very well she's
gone to do a viewing now I'm not sure
what she did prior to that apartment
delegate but she is very good at that
she's a very strong member I think the
team's secret weapon in my opinion is
Matt okay because Matt can price up
reverbs like that so to be able to do
that in these next 24 hours is huge
because they can tell and investor how
much this Reverb is going to be weakest
it's between Scott and Adriana Scott's
very knowledgeable
but I don't think he leads the group
very well with that he doesn't
he doesn't command their attention he
could do this Challenge on his own but
he's not commanding and telling that and
Adriana she's very fixated on this one
property which is great and it might
come off but if it doesn't all her eggs
are in that one basket yeah she's gonna
view it tonight and I think if that
viewing doesn't go how she wants it to
go she could actually be in a bit of a
vulnerable vulnerable position tonight
because I don't know what she's they're
going to focus on next who's the weakest
the weakest at the minute
I've got to say it's probably D she
hasn't picked up the phone but she spent
three hours trying to get onto the Wi-Fi
which
ain't gonna win is it and I'm looking at
Nick like you know
come on say something yeah Nick's The
Negotiator he's got it with he's good
with the agents I think Jody will be
good with the investors so she's got
contact she's got contacts oh she's
already been on the phone yeah I think
they're trying to get some money in the
bank tonight brilliant she works she's
working on a lot of bespoke agreements
Adam's decent he's all right what's his
strong point because he's a lovely guy
yeah very knowledgeable yeah
the best art I think he's he's strong
point I think we'll probably see
tomorrow when it comes to the selling
all right but in terms of against me and
you yeah obviously I usually win
do you though usually do we say usually
all the time I always win there's no way
you're winning this
there's no way I think I've got the
stronger team yeah but they've got the
stronger Mentor yeah but what are you
doing how many phone calls have you made
I'm delegating
oh
how'd your viewing go that you had
arranged for tonight ideally I wanted to
get it done tomorrow because Cloud's
about 30 40 minutes they want to go
there just for one View and I'd rather
do it as a block so you canceled it yeah
they've had a book in but they've
canceled it because they didn't want to
go out and just view what a one property
which I think was a bit daft
so you investors that you've got ready
to go have you qualified them have they
got the funds are they are they good to
go mine are already pre-qualified
they've already got the funds they've
already signed an NDA they already know
they already know this bill and then we
need to organize ourselves to do the
proper viewings and like because without
viewing we can't take the deal and we
can't sell the deal
please don't let me down please don't
let me down we can't let Chris win we
cannot let Chris and his team win bye
guys
if they don't win
I do fear for Nick
I think you'd be in a bit of hot water I
think you're being a bit of bother just
because he's probably got the most
experience out of them all and he's and
he's obviously leading the team
we'll see we'll see what happens
tomorrow night in the boardroom
hey Chris
also we've got um Adriana and Matt
they've gone over to chingford so they
should have got through the door already
they are looking at that right now Scott
and I we went over to the property in
reading and you know it looks like it
could be a good brr to potential HMO so
we're now back at the house we're
running the numbers for that we've been
making calls left right in center so
we've got a call about a potential
off-market doing elim so me and Scott
I'll go in there tonight about 11
because it's um on a lock box it's a
flat for 500 000 with a potential gdv
750. all right good in terms of money in
the bank are we any closer how's money
in the bank loved him so we've got
Adriana and um Matt they have that
they're investors who are kind of like
lukeish warm so I've said to them I told
the investor you're going to negotiate
what it is that they're looking for make
them pay now and then should that
negotiation not meet their requirements
then we just say we'll find you another
deal sounds great
to be fair you might be interested in
this what time are you here tomorrow
well actually that if I could buy the
deal but apparently if I get the rules
oh is it okay never mind you just have
to miss out that's all thank you bye bye
guys
[Music]
yeah it's prep day yeah we've got what
Freeview is booked in Reading tomorrow
are potentially another two in style
head to Slough first thing in the
morning when the estate agent's open and
then go from there
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
get some viewings booked in if you can
and meet back in that for five to 20
minutes yeah God's good question
I've been I've been there close you know
hey are you doing it right once you've
been one or two beds available to you
today it's a Friday I know but I thought
on the office
24 hours yeah I know that it's a shame
we can't do anything today I can
normally show you on like the same day
bacon bacon yeah
foreign
so this morning we've been um on five
UNS now we're off to Windsor they've
potentially got five rental rents for us
the rest of the team are in Birmingham
they have got a landlord or an agent
about three renter to rent essays
[Music]
they're not really doing some viewings
today I'm about to head back to Slough I
wanted to hopefully see anything that
wasn't actually available today
yeah at the moment I find a bit hard to
kind of get viewings
um one is Friday and through the market
so hot at the moment people are not
moving so there's no vacant properties
you know what I mean
weekly
I just spotted one development deal in
Windsor it's a little bit off par of
what we were doing but I think Dee's
motive behind it is kind of cool in the
sense that you can potentially view the
land without having to you know secure a
time slot with the vendor because we
very tied in time and we're struggling
to get viewings uh one by one that
development would work really well for
us and we can take a risk you know just
to view the land and have a chance
send them a message we have a deal this
deal
are you prepared to pay to find this fee
today if we send you the rough breakdown
if for example the do you own due
diligence it doesn't work we'll then
refund you the money and why there's no
point going to the Beauty Land
a development deals takes actually a few
weeks to work for numbers to package the
deal but today I have only a few hours
to do this so I'm just doing everything
in one time
what's the situation with this one this
one against probate probate how long has
it been on Market so again this one was
sold yeah that buyer still wants to buy
it right he's having struggles with
mortgage he needs to wait for credit
score to come in okay and drag on for a
bit too long so the owner family so they
want to remarket it possibility to go up
a lot of people around the road has gone
up okay extending now
for sure yeah I think this could be
really good
it's all right now it's hard to [ __ ]
sell flips
that's what people want yeah there you
go back underground
100 Grand profit's a good deal
yeah
yeah
[Music]
so I rang you yesterday to pry me up and
say that I'll add something that we're
going to be coming coming out today an
investment for you so so I've managed to
package it all up last night and looked
at all the numbers and everything and I
think I've got something for you they'll
be really good just to give you a bit of
background on it it's a
220k purchase price like I said I've
been up I've been up and viewed it
already I've been up and calculated
um the refurb 80k
the the end value then end valuation
I've spoke with a couple of estate
agents around there they've confidently
said to me that it will easily easily go
above 400. so you know the time you
refinance it later on down the line This
is potentially a no money uh no money
left India whatsoever definitely a good
deal I've got to move fairly fast on
this one uh what I'm today it needs to
be gone today really I've got a finance
fee on this one if you want to reserve
it today
up 6K
and if are you are you would you be in a
position today to pay that Founders fee
before the end of play maybe five
o'clock if I get if I get some stuff
over to you with some terms and
conditions and stuff would you be in a
position position to pay that today
yeah right well what I'll do contact
Adriana one of my colleagues on this one
I'm gonna get it sended over some terms
and conditions
um I'll get her a send an invoice over
like I said we will need we will need
payment today because it's going to go
otherwise we'll just because we've got
people queuing up for it okay right up
it is pick somebody
thank you bye-bye bye cheers
[Laughter]
relax kind of
turns out to the land though okay great
you've got the land deal the challenge
is really money in the bank today so
unless he's willing to pay today it's
kind of wasting time he is going to pay
today we'll tell him if you trust me you
know me pay the money now if after I
didn't see it you don't like it I will
give you the money back but I need to
see it I know you need to but this is
we're time sensitive it's one hour and I
can still find thousand deal yeah but he
might okay if you've got money in the
bank at least we've secured it you have
commitment
you don't have a commitment get
commitment from him
that's what I'm saying get commitment
from it
ready is that something you are
interested in I am looking for so are
you in a position to pay the finest fee
up front and obviously I will secure
that for you today we've got a lot of
people that are interested in this deal
and it's probably going to go by five
o'clock tonight
okay brilliant
thank you
I've got a couple of really good deals
but one in particular I think you'd
really like is a rent to rent for an
essay is it something you'd be
interested in still
yeah I'm certain yeah where is it uh
it's in Reading so three grand is your
thought simply correct yeah that's right
are you in a position to pay for that
today
yeah yeah now send me that NDA straight
away quick read through it and if it's
all good I'll secure it all right top
man all right cheers Johnny really
appreciate your business hope to work
with you again in the future yeah yeah
cheers buddy speak to you soon
cheers
hey Chris you're right yeah what's in
the bank right now how much we got in
the bank six grand six grand brilliant
boys listen though I've got news for you
right so I know that the other team yeah
as well
6K right so all about money in the bank
now it's just focus on getting that
money in the banks we don't want to be
looking two of us all right right up it
is
[Music]
so yeah well just had a phone call with
Chris basically just trying to give us a
bit of boot up yeah it just informs the
other team are on the exact same figure
that we are so we need to really open
this game and get those other deals sold
off quick but as fast as possible get
the money in the bank while they're not
really into it yeah we're going back now
we're calling our investors uh packaging
the dealers up I think our Target's got
to be 10 deals we've got to go for it to
sell we need to be certain that we're
going to win this
so rent to service accommodation wise
we have three available for you to pick
your choice from if you desire
it's like a small for Choice exactly so
we've got Birmingham which is a two bed
house this one cash flowing at 70 so
we've been conservative on it at 70 this
is Cash flowing 870. now reading at 80
that one is Cash flowing 900 profit per
month Windsor obviously Windsor is
Windsor's Windsor yeah it's lucrative
place it's a basement apartment so we've
been interviewed this one today again
this one at 80 percent is Cash flowing
uh 1100 a month uh out of them three
which which one is sort of I think
[Music]
is that is that what you want to go over
you could talk to yourself you could
talk something to all three of them if
you like for me
thank you very much
get in I'm not being funny but I've just
said to you about that deal and you said
Evans has got it and then you've just
sold it so why are you telling me I
can't sell it and now you're selling it
what's up with you I've just told you
what's up because you're just telling me
one thing and doing another and I'm just
playing about it
nothing I'm telling you facts what I'm
telling you facts you've just got
freaking money in the bank again yeah
I'll get money in the bank right well
come on then let's get money in the bank
then just try to cause a stone because
because you're bullshitting me Ivan
bullshitted
for yourself and you told me something
and then yeah
just as a team we just want to win so we
are not in the bottom but we want to do
it in a way where you know it's powerful
and we're happy and joyous
everything's going good
on the deal side of things no when we
talk about the person side of things
there's a moment of friction and tension
and I think when you're so passionate
about something and you're really
determined and driven there can be you
know there can be a clash and I kind of
gave them a moment to get it out don't
call me alive so I'm not a liar I've not
called I've not caused a stir all right
and deceitful because that's not in my
[ __ ] nature so don't say I've been
like that and then once I felt the boat
had a moment to get their point out I
helped to bring them back into focus of
what we're actually trying to do and
Achieve I'm not listening
all right you guys need to just take a
break it's been a very good right there
yeah right I've not deceived your by any
means I would not do that right cool
right yeah
foreign
but we've got [ __ ]
we need the other two to come back with
something because this is almost so far
yeah I know
Amy you're right yeah you're good yeah
so just be the property nice to go very
good location uh it's very kind of good
order what it is I'm gonna put it to
someone else but if you want it I want
to kind of get it secured so look I need
to get wrapped up by in the next hour or
so
if I can bring the sourcing feed down I
said I'm looking to secure a deal today
in the next hour so if I can bring it
down to 50 below what the normal fee is
so 1500 pounds in the in the bank today
and how how does that sound
so we're going back hill now yeah yeah
while we're going back we still have one
hour we can even like show to other
investors while we're going home
and I hope we will sell at least one
deal
we've got a really good deal in in
Reading basically it's a 600 Grand
purchase though it is have you got that
kind of money
the refurb is 130k you're all in for
about 750 just over 750 and then it's
worth 900 so you're making about 150
150k clean profit if you flipped it if
you want it then I can send you an
invoice in terms and conditions it's a
three thousand pound deposit it needs
done within like say next half an hour
if I sent you times and conditions and
and the bank details you'll you'll
transfer the money
yeah all right yeah that's great thank
you
cheers
bye bye bye
[Applause]
are you floating on it
the final crunch you can't be ringing
agents you can't you can't be doing
viewings all you can do is try and sell
the stuff that you've done and hope
people act quickly
[Music]
we're looking like a three thousand
pound finders fee but it's a really good
deal
[Music]
what is I got 20 minutes to secure this
deal
check also check your Jumpman as well
time's ticking
how should you pay that's like my
favorite line
yes okay okay
well I look forward to do business with
you I will go with it so let me know
when you need the money I'll make sure
it's in the bank oh that sounds
brilliant oh I'm gonna cry I just gotta
do this on a regular occurrence I'll be
absolutely minted on Yachts soon
[Music]
all of these are people who said they
are going to send the money right now so
our next step is actually going on to
that account because you know it's not
sold until you see the goals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if we don't win this
I don't know what the hell they've done
they must have had Adam walking on and
working in some clubs or something I
don't know they're definitely more than
that today I'm apprehensive as to
whether we'd be in the other team I
really don't know they kept cheering
we've kept Taco so I don't know I think
it's going to be close
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
welcome to the boardroom this was task
two and you guys smashed out the park so
congratulations the next team how did it
go Nick absolutely fantastic great team
great effort and confident cherelle how
did you get on this team leader really
good how we all got on was amazing
putting our ideas in amazing good if
someone was evicted from your team who
would it be
it shouldn't be anybody no but if
someone was otherwise it's you
wow
we all heard a lot of power but if we
talk about you know
we some of us have louder voices than
others you were the team leader who
contributed the least it's very simple
question
there was no lease contribution because
everyone bought different things to the
team who sold the lease
who sold the lease yes because it was a
sales competition who sold the least
Adriana so at least Adriana yeah how
much did you sell I sold one deal I
haven't outside too but I was also the
driver last night and the driver today
the maximum effort was put in to do
everything we found the deals that you
sold I found the deal that I sold yeah
Nick who's the weakest link in your team
I would say unfortunately I would be
Deep D again okay the reason being
because
we're selling deals here and we're
talking about renting to rails probably
would be the best strategy and a lot of
the conversation came about Land
Development deal which I knew was to
take a long time and a couple coming up
and up and again even for my mentors
said look let's scrap This Land
Development deal what happened with that
Ellie you were their Mentor what
happened yeah so derang me this morning
said I've got this Land Development deal
we were talking about it and the
conclusion I came to was look you've got
eight hours scrap it but it sounds like
you've been dealing with this land deal
all day so how did you respond to
Elliot's advice when he told you to just
knock it on the head how did you respond
to that day
I just took this like a professional
advice but I also uh um knew that I can
live this deal in the end so did you
knock it on the head or did you continue
I think I just left it is that correct
guys I would listen literally say
something if you had the investor that
was prepared to pay money on account
that's what I said to you right please
prepare to pay money on account but the
five thousand pound he knows you then
great fantastic that works and then we
can work out the rest of their work out
the details later deals you could have
sold these regiment deals I had I found
the deals so if you had your attention a
little bit it would have helped a little
bit that's what I'm saying how much
damage did you sell in the end
so I secured two deals uh we sent it off
the DD so the NDA sorry at the last
minute you're going into a training and
I'm unable to return that money back in
I said how did you not manage to make a
single sale like this is your thing man
how did you get on Joe day I should
surprise myself
I sold four deals and I closed D's deal
as well I've done the best I've ever
done in my life
do you want to say anything Adam
it's been a learning experience that's
for sure this was my Achilles heel I
felt like it was my biggest weakness but
I've grown so much the confidence I've
got from just doing it it's been amazing
Scott
I hear that you had a little bit of
drama with with Matt talk to me about
that I'll just set standards in in my
life and if if things drop below that
then I'm going to say something about it
so so what was the standard that Matt
did not meet uh I thought that he uh
yeah just uh went behind my back and
lied to me about stuff so that's huge
serious Matt what'd you have to say
about that completely not true it's just
a miscommunication along the line that
uh the deal was specific for is investor
and my purpose so sole purpose for the
task was get money in the bank for the
team and Scott saw that as me deceiving
him which wasn't the case whatsoever I I
had a list of rent to rents that were
all needed selling so I got uninformed
to my investor I read the list out to
him asked him what were more more
appealing to him and that specific deal
just happened to be the one that Scott
wanted for his investor we've agreed it
well well I thought we didn't until
until Scott said that I thought we'd
agree and it were miscommunication
so your team did really well overall you
managed to bring cash in the bank of 18
000 pounds which is really good
[Music]
your team with a winning team with 24
000 pounds
congratulations you're the winning team
we've also booked you a beautiful boat
ride in the morning
to celebrate so well done you can go
back into the house congratulations
[Music]
you guys did well you made 18 000 pounds
which to be honest did exceed my
expectations but you just weren't strong
compared to the other group you made 24
000 pounds so unfortunately two of you
will have to be evicted this evening and
terminated from the process
Jody what did you actually bring to the
challenge I brung the most money how
much money did you bring in
15 grand 15 grand
how did you think Jody did neck as team
leader actually did awesome I can't fool
her on this challenge uh she wanted to
socks off she's a deal saucer by trade
and that's why I was happy to have her
on my team and yeah so I can't afford to
earlier well in the last challenge in
the boardroom you know I was I could
definitely see a fire and I wasn't quite
sure how that was going to pan out but
it's clearly you're clearly proven
yourself and I'm I'm very impressed with
you Joe day and I know Elliot as well
and you know we're very impressed with
what you've done I mean 15 000 pounds
single-handedly in 24 hours absolutely
incredible and I think that you're the
kind of person that I definitely want to
be sticking around so you can go back to
the house thank you
I mean between the three of you you made
three grand Jody made 15 grand so how
much did you bring in three grand three
grand okay so D Nick you didn't bring
anything in
a bit of a shambles today I'm going to
be honest with you the first two hours
of the challenge yesterday you were
trying to get on the Wi-Fi you didn't
make any phone calls within the first
couple of hours Nick to be fair was on
the phone outside Adam was on the phone
Jody was on the phone you for the first
two hours moaning about the Wi-Fi
do you think if you'd have stuck to the
strategy of selling rent to rent deals
do you think you might have sold a few
more as opposed to messing about with
this land deal with 12 hours yes So
eventually like I sold deal but it
didn't go on time because of the bank
problems because
until the money hits the account yes
yeah so you didn't sell anything
he came close to selling something did
you come close to selling anything yes
we had the person agreed it he was
actually going on a train and said look
get the NDA over to me uh send the money
but unfortunately it was past the cut
off point before did the money come in
afterwards or not no I had really high
hopes for you in this challenge as well
because this is what you do yeah so
security securing the deals I'm not
necessarily a deal sourcer by trade no
but you're a sales yeah 100 so I secured
the deals I had some fantastic news at
the start had a block deal it was
unfortunate we're going to get
interviewed because it was talented that
was one of the struggles we had today I
don't want to hear that unfortunately
struggle problem issue excuse
So Adam
do you think Nick was a good team leader
I do yeah I think he started very strong
um I would definitely say he's a good
team he's definitely a grafter yeah 100
you know and he's definitely good uh
he's good businessman good salesman I'm
just disappointed in my one sale in
terms of I think I let the team off how
can you lead a team well when you didn't
even make one sale leading a team is
leading by example if everyone had done
what you'd have done you'd have made
nothing
Chris what are you thinking got to be
honest I had massive hopes for Adam with
this challenge I just want to know kind
of what happened to your end not to have
sold as much as Jody did cool sure
um Jody actually sells quite a few of
the deals that I actually secured
um why why didn't you sell them yeah
this was a deal selling challenge yeah
I'm not a deal seller per se well you
got to be a seller it's not one of my
strengths well it has to be a strength
are you going to get on in business and
get through to the to the final if you
just stand here not only did you not
sell that well but to say I'm not a
salesperson I don't sell well owning the
fact that you're not a good salesperson
for me is is is is just not good enough
who do you think should be evicted Adam
it's a difficult decision but I would
probably lean towards
dude you did so well in the last
challenge as well with the interior
designs
or with all due respect interior design
and making properties look nice ain't
gonna they're gonna make your
multi-millionaire is it
I think with Adam and Nick say you were
the weakest intestine I'm very sorry but
you are evicted
[Music]
it's really a toss-up now between Nick
and Adam Adam did more Adam sold a deal
Adam secure deals that got sold Nick
didn't really do anything
but then at the same time I know that
Nikki is a grafter Nick did lead the
team well and the team did make 18 Grand
so
Nick why do you think you should stay
over Adam again I want to be here I
didn't believe I could win it I do
believe Adam is a strong candidate but I
believe I'm the best hit I think
everyone hears a potential otherwise I
wouldn't have got you in the in in the
process I mean if you and me Nick who
would you evict right now if you're
looking on paper you'll say Adam is a
stable so if you bought three thousand
pounds in yeah but if you're looking in
terms of the deeper level in terms of
the experience across the whole pressure
of property sales doing actually what
hmos rent to rent bras is I'm a complete
package doing that just unfortunate
those deals are particular deals didn't
get yeah no I can see that Adam do you
think I should evict Nick or yourself
foreign
you will go if you keep being this nice
why shouldn't it go out of you
give us something I'm here to learn from
you guys should be here to win we need
more we need more fire I've got a lot of
fire I've got a lot we need to see it
because I'm better
believe it I am I'm better
I'll show you you keep me in I've not
got a lot of experience in sales you're
teaching me very well on how to sell and
you know there's something that I am
actively working on I have held my hands
up and said this is probably my weakest
point and it's something that I'm
actively working on but there's other
areas within property I feel like I'm
very strong I do believe in you and I do
obviously I wouldn't have you in the
process otherwise but the thing for me
is just saying I'm not a good sales
person for me I just really can't
tolerate that just owning a weakness
which is such a strong importance to
business like sales I am a better
salesman today
Nick has definitely got a lot going for
you I think you did lead the team wow
you grafted but you didn't sell a single
deal
I've made my decision
[Music]
Aaron you brought 3 000 pounds in Nick
you didn't bring any money in so Nick
you're evicted
Adam
you round to round three
we want to see more in round three I
won't be disappointed in you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I have a feeling right now a bit gutted
obviously I didn't get to just go
through the whole process I said I
wouldn't be here with everything I could
win it because yeah it's a bit
disappointed that they got further in
the challenge
I feel that it's a little bit like oh
I'm off you know but also I know that I
didn't do my best
I think they're all very very strong I
think Adam I think he's good I think
Matt is fantastic as well Jody
because I had the chance to be with her
and I think she is very strong she
should be a winner you get all depends
in terms of what the challenges are and
who shines are both I think everyone has
a chance to win it
I'm proud of myself and that I am here
and I had the opportunity to be around
those successful people and I learned so
much and that environment was amazing so
I think what the eviction gives you is
that confidence and kind of go out and
don't wait until tomorrow don't wait
until six months just go out and live
today go out pull out 100. I just want
to say good luck for smart for talented
for funny for amazing people and I wish
success for everybody
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is the worst viewing I've ever done
in my entire life it's going to be
really challenging for whoever can do it
will be worth the twenty thousand pound
eat it read it sleep it and I guarantee
you
they can say as much as the one but I've
got the most knowledge I made that deal
it's my deal
I'm right
you're evicted